let me pull up the story from
timcast.com this is you may have heard
the news governor abbott bars vaccine
mandates in texas the state's
legislature previously banned local
governments and school districts from
requiring vaccines or masks this is big
it's that simple
now joe biden's executive order
for
uh the osha rule 100 employees or more
it's not it doesn't exist it was just a
press conference it's not there there's
no executive voter on the books and osha
has not implemented this rule however
abbott is saying in texas you cannot you
cannot have vaccine mandates southwest
is based in dallas
so what are they going to do are they
going to you know so what are they going
to now
if they do this they're going to get
fined i guess per per employer or
however it worked a thousand bucks but
think about this what happens if osha
does drop this rule
let's say you're a business in texas
and you're told by the governor if you
mandate vaccines for your employees or
customers we will fine you a thousand
bucks per infraction but then you get
the fed saying if you don't we will find
you way more per infraction
so do you think this is why the
southwest ceo is saying what he's saying
about not liking vaccine mandates or
mass mandates or whatever he's got he
can't do anything about it i mean you
got
this
i just got to slow down pick a side
that's where we're at pick a side yeah
that's what bothers me this is an
example of fighting authoritarianism
with authoritarianism what abbott did i
think is a step too far he he basically
mandated that no one can authorize
vaccines he's telling the private
companies
he's saying so so the federal government
said everyone has to do it then abbott
set in and came in and said no one's
allowed to do it and you know why what
he should sure already along the book
saying you can't discriminate for
medical reasons so what he should have
said is you don't have to listen to the
federal government you can do whatever
you want no the the mandate specifically
says that individuals are allowed
exemptions for religious personal
conscience or medical reasons so this is
what's effectively shutting down the
vaccine minutes that people can just
choose not to get them due to personal
conscience there's already laws in the
book saying you can't discriminate for
medical or religious reasons as far as i
can tell and correct me if i'm wrong
abbott's telling every private company
in texas that they're not allowed to
mandate vaccines now should they be
allowed to uh
ban people if they're black
i don't know i don't think so why or if
they're a civil rights law yeah or if
they're in a wheelchair should should
they be allowed to ban wheelchairs
or people without aids or cameras well
it depends on the job you know certain
things require certain amounts of
activity so like if you need someone to
climb ladders you can't hire someone in
wheelchairs but that's that's a form of
discrimination
so if you need somebody to
uh work in a grocery store and there are
jobs that can be done a grocery store
that someone in a wheelchair can do
should they be allowed to say no
wheelchairs allowed
what about what about a muslim person
should they be like no no i get that
muslim stuff out here i should be able
to they think that violates
yes and there's also the the amer uh the
ada the americans with disabilities act
so now you've got medical reasons and we
shouldn't have to present our papers to
our doctor to the store to prove
should a person who's got some kind of
like uh not you know should someone have
to go and prove that they're the right
race and they say oh you know i'm not
firing you because of your race because
you i don't even know if that's your
real race you should they have to go and
go pull up lineage no you don't got to
prove it we just make the case when we
complain the point is i i agree to an
excerpt to a certain extent abbot should
we shouldn't have rule by decree
however these are different situations
if the law already states you can't
discriminate for religious reasons and
medical reasons and it does
case yeah if someone says it is against
my deeply held moral and and spiritual
and religious or whatever beliefs
they should be yeah but you don't have
to hire someone with leprosy if they
come in there that's different what's
different about it i mean come on bro i
mean it's different to me because we pay
attention but you know in the mind of a
business owner who's who's the governor
to say who they can and can't that's a
different question because in one case
you're asking about somebody who already
has a disease and the second case you're
asking about not whether someone has a
disease but whether or not they've been
vaccinated not whether or not they're
sick so in the case of the leprosy thing
you'd say well you already have it you
can give it to somebody whereas in the
case of the vaccine thing do you have
covid no i don't have government not too
bad
why because you're not vaccinated
right that's this that's the uh that's
the separation point what i would ask is
whether or not for all the people who
are pushing the covet thing
could a bar owner say nobody with stds
is allowed to come to ladies night
we want we want couples to get together
and you've got to bring your papers
that's right brandon you have to you
have to disclose to us your hiv status
would people be comfortable with that of
course they wouldn't or or would people
be comfortable saying look you have to
have your vaccine for hep c before you
can come in would people be comfortable
with that
for me the question is how far can these
things get pushed
and i understand
vax passports i understand why people
want them but the
the question that no one has been able
to ask to answer for me is
where is the hard and fast line that it
stops no one's been able to give me an
answer to that and that's why i'm so
skeptical of them let's add another
element here let's talk about this you
know vaccine that stops stds the vaccine
that stops this hypothetical that we're
talking about doesn't stop stds it
doesn't prevent the spread of stds it
doesn't stop people from having stds as
well on top of all of this which people
need to understand the greater point
here so so you know there's so many
different ways that people could take
this there's if we're starting to
discriminate against people because of
their medical personal choices and
decisions you know let's first discuss
that and even on those merits whether
the you know the effective see of the
vaccine the transmission of the vaccine
natural immunity i think that
conversation needs to happen in this
first place the second thing is no one
should be telling me what to do a
government shouldn't be controlling
every aspect of my existence because
because if they could do this with the
vaccine they could do this with almost
every other aspect of our existence and
it's basically telling business owners
what to do he's saying you can sign an
executive order saying that vaccine
mandates are not allowed by any entity
right so it's a form of authoritarianism
now maybe he did the right thing i
disagree because he's standing up for
people's civil rights he's standing up
for people's personal decisions he's
standing up to the current kind of hipaa
laws that are out there that says that
people can't be discriminated against
and have to divulge their medical
history
already uh evident he doesn't need to
mandate civil rights to people he just
needs to protect them from the
government's overreach south southwest
is literally violating
social norms and law
and they can go work at a different
texas i mean this is the i think it
starts to break down is when it's a when
it's a national company with with a
satellite in texas this is this is this
is really interesting because we did
have this conversation before it may
have been with michael malus the the
argument you're making is the argument
that was made by by conservatives and uh
maybe conservatives at the right word
but it was made by the the democrats to
stop civil rights they said the
government should not have the authority
to mandate a private business
you know uh not discriminated they can
serve whatever they want if someone
doesn't want to work there or someone
was like go they don't have to go there
that was always the argument
then you had the the social uh you know
people fighting for civil rights
specifically saying public
accommodations are shared by all if
we're all paying taxes into it then we
should all be able to utilize these
services my view of it is if there is
limited space in the commons
and there is a building occupying space
in that commons and my tax dollars go
towards infrastructure plumbing fire
department ems on all that they should
not be allowed to discriminate against
me or anybody else
on specific grounds that of course we
need to sort through an outline now we
have outlines many of them religious
reasons you can't put up a sign saying
no muslims allowed
you can't mandate that people eat bacon
to enter your store because that would
very serious someone walk in i mean
maybe you can but then if someone who
was muslim walked up and they said do it
you'd be like you can't do that that's
discrimination on the basis of my
religion and you'd probably get in
trouble there's a guy who went to jail
for throwing bacon at a mosque
so so right now abbott is basically
saying
these these mandates just violate so
many of our non-discrimination laws you
can't do this public accommodation is
for all if we are paying taxes into it
we are a community to maintain social
cohesion you cannot restrict access to
someone on the basis of their medical
reasons or religious reasons or personal
moral conscious reasons now it's tough
it is because personal moral conscience
is a broad term but he said that in his
executive order because it's basically
about religion there's a lot of people
who are saying oh but the pope said you
can get the vaccine even though it's you
they use fetal cells to make it in the
testing process and its other vaccines
they literally use it and these aren't
testing for a bunch of other medicines
the pope says it's fine well i don't
care what the pope thinks and i'm sure
there's a whole lot of other catholics
who don't care that the pope has said
that they're like nah that that goes
against our religious values
so if we already have the laws on the
books
than him simply saying hey guys i am
reinforcing that you cannot discriminate
so i guess we're all in agreement that
sometimes authoritarianism is necessary
and good no that's what abbot just did
not
hold on there a minute you mean decades
of civil rights work to get laws put on
the books through legislation and
elected representatives who then voted
on it is authoritarianism no i'm saying
him making a decree like this is
authoritarian making a decree to
reinstate to to reaffirm what is all
just like just like desegregating
schools that was authoritarianism you
can see how it works sometimes
desegregating schools was the part of a
long process it was resulted in a
republic having a vote on an issue
so authoritarianism was when everyone
just falls in line and adheres to the
authority like the cult
when people have strong objections and
and and disagreements and then we say
hey we all have finally agreed this is
the line
you have to you can't discriminate and
it was through a democratic
representative process
sure you can argue that people are oh no
they have to adhere to the authority of
the state because we all agreed to it
but there's a big difference between we
fought long and hard we won over hearts
and minds we got our elected
representatives put in office they voted
for it then the supreme court upheld it
and now we're at a point where the
governor is saying guys the law is clear
you can't do this i am not going to
allow you to because as the head of the
executive branch of my state i am here
to enforce the laws that already exist
that's not authoritarianism joe biden
issuing an edict where he convinces
people there's along the books when
there isn't and they all start following
him that's authoritarianism it's both
it's just two two governors making
declarations about what to do telling
people what they can and can't do wait
wait is your objection that is your
objection that it was made by the
governor and not by the state
legislature definitely okay firstly and
secondly i don't like the government
telling private companies what they can
and can't do i'm very nervous and
reticent about that kind of thing so i
noticed it when it happened
i i don't think this is authoritarianism
ian i think this is simply him
reinforcing the fact that we have civil
rights and that no one should have the
right to require someone to get a
medical procedure if they don't want it
this has always been the case this is
just him reminding everyone that this is
the case and not he's not even
necessarily putting anything new into
effect
let me ask another question if a bunch
of businesses in texas started banning
black people and then he issued an
executive order saying the banning of
black people is prohibited would you
call that authoritarianism
yeah but there's already a law in the
book through a democratic process
well him saying something skin color is
different than disease um you know you
can suspend habeas corpus in times of
great disease
i mean you maybe can as obviously you
can but
i i don't think it's not about disease
it's about vaccination
if this was about if
there's nothing in there that prevents a
a company from saying we'd like you to
take a rapid antigen covert test before
you enter our business right presented
rapid energy cover test we don't want
anyone with covid but that's not what
that's about this is about vaccination
not disease and i think there's a
dividing line there if a business wants
to say look we're only going to have
people come in who have tested negative
for covert i would say
all right well if you want to make
everyone take an antigen test before
they come in or present an antigen just
i guess you want to do that that's fine
but there's a difference between saying
you have to give us an uh an antigen
test so that we know whether you have
covert or not we're keeping the covet
out not you on the one hand or on the
other hand say
only if you're vaccinated because then i
mean think of the absurdity that comes
in the guy who says i've tested negative
for covet i don't have covet i can't go
in another guy says i tested positive
for covert but i'm faxed see you all
there
and many people who do take the vaccine
do test positive yeah so someone with a
breakthrough case can go in with covet
and cough all over everywhere because
they're vaccinated and someone who's not
who's not sick doesn't have covalent is
tested negative can't go in because he's
not vaccinated right this is not about
disease it's about using the withdrawal
of the ability to use services as a
cudgel to beat people who aren't getting
vaccinated and that's i think a
difference and i want to break this down
what we're seeing at the federal level
with biden in the democrats versus texas
with joe biden on multiple occasions now
he said the legislative legislature be
damned i will exact executive decree on
the eviction moratorium and now with the
with the osha rule those things need to
go through the congress we also have the
supreme court saying no to him with the
eviction moratorium and him being like
don't care i'll do it anyway and he did
and then democrats cheered for it abbott
is saying guys there are laws in the
book saying you can't do this and i am
obligated to enforce those i am telling
you right now this cannot be done as per
existing law florida
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time